l'assemblée nationale il y a quelques
semaines richard est entré par hasard
dans le restaurant de philippe les deux
hommes sont tombés amoureux
ils vivent une belle histoire d'amour et
s'ils le souhaitent ils pourront bientôt
se marier
depuis peu c'est possible les députés en
ont décidé ainsi
le mariage entre deux hommes ou entre
deux femmes et maintenant légal
l'assemblée nationale avec ses députés a
pour fonction de délimiter par la loi ce
qui est interdit et ce qui est permis
les temps et les moeurs changent la loi
avec 7 au moment de la révolution que
l'on a décidé que c'était le peuple qui
devait définir les règles de notre vie
en société
cela s'appelle la souveraineté populaire
aujourd'hui toutes les démocraties du
monde ont un parlement élu en france
il est composé de l'assemblée nationale
et du sénat souvent il se présente sous
la forme d'un hémicycle dans le jargon
politique on appelle ça le camembert et
comme on ne peut pas mettre tout le
peuple dans une boîte à camembert on
serait un peu serré on élit des délégués
comme en classe mais pour cinq ans ce
sont les députés
en france ils sont 577 vous remarquerez
qu'il ya surtout des hommes le plus
souvent d'une cinquantaine d'années
pendant longtemps on a considéré que
faire la loi c'était un travail d'homme
là encore les moeurs évoluent maintenant
chaque parti politique doit c'est une
loi présenté autant de femmes que
d'hommes on appelle ça la parité mais ça
ne marche pas encore génialement et les
partis politiques préfèrent payer des
amendes plutôt que de respecter la loi
des députés qui s'arrange avec la loi
c'est un peu nul mais c'est sûr ça va
changer la loi est censée aussi protéger
les plus faibles les députés décident de
limiter parfois notre liberté pour
protéger celle des autres on n'a pas le
droit de voler les pommes de son voisin
sous prétexte qu'on a envie d'une pomme
les députés ne peuvent pas voter
n'importe quelle loi la loi doit
respecter la grande règle du jeu de la
démocratie la constitution je vous
expliquerai ce que c'est plus tard par
exemple la loi doit être la même pour
tout le monde les députés ne peuvent pas
interdire aux blondes de faire des
études ou exonérés d'impôts les
habitants de la ville du président de la
république des juges
les membres du conseil constitutionnel
sont chargés de vérifier si les lois
sont conformes à la constitution
les députés doivent aussi contrôler le
gouvernement pour vérifier que les
ministres applique bien les lois ils
peuvent faire des enquêtes demandé des
explications au ministre par exemple
lors des questions d'actualité que l'on
peut voir à la télé les députés se
disputent parfois ils critiquent le
gouvernement
mais l'assemblée c'est fait pour ça ce
sont nos représentants et grâce à eux
nous les français on ne se tape pas
dessus ils le font pour nous tous les
ans ils votent la loi la plus importante
le budget c'est à dire qu'il décide qui
paiera des impôts et combien parce que
son resto a cartonné avec sa recette de
couscous à la chantilly philippe s'est
fait beaucoup d'argent cette année comme
ils ne sont pas encore mariés il paiera
plus d'impôts que richard parce que
richard travaille dans une usine de
voitures qui n'a pas beaucoup vendu de
voiture ça s'appelle la solidarité
nationale le budget voté par l'assemblée
nationale et le sénat sert à payer les
instituteurs les policiers faire des
routes ou des écoles l'assemblée et ses
députés doivent faire en sorte grâce à
leurs lois que nous puissions le mieux
possible
vivre ensemble philippe richard et nous
tous